this is a story I'd been meaning to get
to I'm glad we finally have time
breaking news if you're driving please
pull over if you're standing up please
sit down Mars candy will be releasing
all female packs of M MS
yes finally
how
is the candy female I well the way that
the candy's female is that they've got
those little cartoons that they put in
the commercials and some of the cartoons
are men and some of the cartoons are
women this this issue actually came up
about a year ago because uh Eminem's
announced that the green m m was no
longer going to be sexy previously the
green m m was really really hot and sexy
as far as candy coated chocolates go and
then they decided they were going to
make the green m m kind of frumpy and
sexually ambiguous so okay
going with the culture I guess uh but
now now they're saying okay we're going
to release all female packs
and why are they doing that because they
want to quote celebrate women everywhere
who are flipping the status quo and it's
really funny because the pack actually
just shows these women upside down these
women hanging by their feet completely
upside down it doesn't seem very
celebratory to me but what does it tell
you about the culture
what this it the Eminem story actually
does tell you something about the
culture we're living in it tells you
that our culture today is glib gay and
contemptuous of our forebears that's
what it is this is so glib so much of
our activism of our real political
discourse in this country
is putting the chick M Ms in the bag
that's how we're going to seriously deal
with the moral and political issues of
our time we're going to post a black
Square on Instagram yeah that's right
you know what we're gonna do we're gonna
start a hashtag yes Michelle Obama
well she was first lady of the United
States well her president was the most
powerful man in the world
posted on social media a picture of
herself holding up a white sheet of
paper that said hashtag bring back our
girls
frat and she was frowning she looked
very serious
because Boko Haram a terrorist group had
kidnapped a bunch of girls said Bring
Back Our Girls
her husband's the president
if if he wanted to get rid of Boko Haram
he could do it in two seconds Boko Haram
these they don't I don't think they have
a nuclear weapons I don't think they're
the most sophisticated or civilized
people in the world
they're a thug terror group
of of people using very old Weaponry who
could be wiped out by the US military in
a morning before lunch
but for any number of reasons Barack
Obama didn't want to go take out Boko
Haram so how are we going to stop it
we're going to hold up hashtags do we
ever get Kony 2012
are we there yet
I'm not so sure very glib culture and a
gay culture and I'm using gay in a
technical sense of that term not to mean
that it's a happy culture it's not a
happy culture but gay meaning we don't
recognize that men need women and women
need men we don't recognize that we
don't recognize that men and women are
complementary our culture views men and
women alternately as identical and
indiscernible
and as in opposition to one another the
old expression used to be that you will
never have a war between the sexes in
this country because everybody is
Sleeping with the Enemy
increasingly that's not so true 20 plus
percent of gen Z identifies as lgbtq so
I don't know maybe you will get a gender
war in the country
it's glib it's gay and it's contentious
of our forebears congratulations to
women for flipping the status quo what's
wrong with the status quo I got plenty
of problems with the status quo because
of how it has upended our our
millennia-long traditions in recent
decades that's my issue with the status
quo but most people's issue on the lit
on the left with the status quo is that
anything that happened in the past
is really bad and evil anything that's
happening right now is a crisis and it's
pretty bad and evil and anything that
happens in the future is going to be
better than the president and the past
that is a culture that is in serious
decline that is a culture I hope it's
not terminal decline but it's a culture
that's given up the the most important
democracy in the world that's the
Democracy of the Dead that does not
merely combine uh the the decisions
about how we live to the people who
happen to be walking on on the earth at
the present moment but actually looks to
the Past receives wisdom recognizes that
maybe we don't know every single thing
that's ever been discovered maybe maybe
a span of 80 years is not enough time to
learn everything that there is to learn
maybe we ought to have a little respect
for history and the Great Men Who came
before us no our culture says no Enjoy
your M Ms my producer Ben Davies has a
story every week that he's upset that I
don't get to and so I've got the story
here facing upside down I will flip it
over and read this story for the first
time you got to go to the member block
to do that okay that is dailywire.com
Knowles use code Knowles at checkout you
will get two months free on all annual
plans see at the member block
[Music]
[Music]